why do you think suicide rates higher  with men  um because men have harder lives  because they I don't know because men  are told from early age they ain't [ __ ]  and if they can't perform the world  tells them quick  so like there are men that don't even  know what it's like to be like the  amount of offers that I have gotten in  DM very weird very stop sending me them  guys like it's but it's it's like sad to  me like I'll hear stories like I'm  addicted to hookers because I've never  had a girl interested in me in my life  ever I've never had a girl even like  express interest in like talking to me  like they don't even  and so  yeah like and I think men like imagine  your life if you've never had a woman  ever interested in talking to you would  you really feel a lot of purpose